[Music]
all right brand-new tonight after a
meeting between Trump the FBI director
Chris Rea rod Rosenstein and other top
Intel officials the White House is
saying President Trump and the
Department of Justice are now asking the
inspector general to investigate the
Obama administration and the spying they
did on the Trump campaign and the White
House is also revealing tonight that
chief of staff John Kelly is general
Kelly is setting up a meeting for
Congress so they will see the documents
that constitutionally they have been
asking for and the DOJ has been
obstructing in stonewalling really I'll
believe it when I see those documents
now this is the same material that rod
Rosenstein has refused to turn over for
months
now his name by the way you want to keep
an eye on I'll have more on Rosen Stein
in a minute now first what's unfolding
about the deep state is so dramatic so
shocking but at the same time so very
predictable given everything we have now
been uncovering for over 18 months now
we are now seeing the cracks in the deep
state in this dam it's about to burst
and all of this information is now
beginning to cascade out even the New
York Times The Washington Post are now
confirming just in the last week
everything we have been uncovering again
for 18 months it is the biggest abuse of
power corruption scandal it makes
Watergate look like a parking ticket now
the house Intel committee chair Devin
noonas he's reacting by saying this is
crossing a serious red line very
important if they ran a spy ring or an
informant ring and they were paying
people within the Trump campaign if any
of that is true that is an absolute
redline there is not an honest person in
this country that thinks it's okay if
sources informants whatever you want to
call them go around and start passing
out money all over the globe to do what
to to secretly put yourself into a
presidential campaign that's not
acceptable in this country that's not
acceptable in the United States of
America
chairman Nunez is also saying there
might be more than one FBI informant
you've got to be kidding me
watch this nobody was ever interested in
an informant we asked for specific
documents that we still have not
received from the Department of Justice
so they continued to leak out things
about this informant and we don't know
if there's one informant or more
informants because there's so much out
there now it's really getting tough to
follow and all we're asking for is give
us the documentation that you used to
start this investigation hand it over
these type of tactics spying on an
opposition party in an election year are
you kidding me
this is what you see in the former
Soviet Union Venezuela
not the United States of America just
look at this quote from The Wall Street
Journal editorial board listen to this
we cannot recall recall a similar case
even the J Edgar Hoover days when the
FBI decided it needed to snoop on a
presidential campaign now this is the
same J Edgar Hoover who was notorious
for having files on just about everyone
in Washington that is how serious all of
this is even Clinton aide and advisor
Mark Penn he's worked with the Clintons
for 20 years is calling out this scandal
for what it is this is a game-changing
moment and Penn has worked for the
Clintons forever and served as Hillary's
chief strategist for her campaign in
2008 he is now calling this witch hunt
for what it is and literally writing an
op-ed in the hill stopping Robert Muller
to protect us all stunning headline Penn
goes on to explain how the facts are now
undeniable Muller is on a crusade to get
the President of the United States to
overturn a duly elected president he
uses the term deep state that it's real
that the FBI rigged the Clinton
investigation and then targeted Donald
Trump and his campaign when he was
president-elect and now president and
Penn explained more on this on the story
with Martha McCallum earlier tonight
take a look I think that the inspector
general's report is coming out I think
noon is is finding out like what are the
origins of the investigation and there
doesn't seem to be a real concrete
intelligence origin for this
investigation and without a
nation one wonders what did we spend an
entire year on what did we disrupt
everyone who was in the campaign
everyone who's in the administration and
also former Solicitor General for the US
Ted Olson he's out with a new piece
where he explains how Robert Muller's
witch-hunt could be setting up a massive
constitutional crisis and of course
investigative reporter cheryl atkinson
she has a defining piece on all of this
literally called the collusion against
trump an entire timeline she breaks down
every single key moment in this entire
massive abuse of power scandal we will
refer to this throughout history because
it's been going on for eighteen months
now the mainstream media even they
finally are starting to catch on and
admit that what we've been reporting and
what others on the show have been
reporting and other people what we've
been covering we're now being proven
right they have to admit it look at this
headline from The Washington Post over
the weekend secret FBI source for Russia
investigation met with three Trump
advisors during the campaign here's a
USA Today report look at this cover it
says and even by the way even fake news
liberal CN n they can't ignore all the
facts all the evidence okay it's taking
them well over a year but finally the
media is starting to realize that they
have missed the single biggest story in
their lifetime as they pursued Russia
and Russia stormy
now it's a massive abuse of power we
first reported on this March 7th 2017
about FISA surveillance of the Trump
campaign President Trump he has every
single right tonight to be outraged
about what has happened he has every
right to want to know the truth you the
American people need to know the truth
we need to expose all of this criminal
behavior all of these deep state actors
need to be exposed and all of them held
accountable the Deputy Attorney General
rod Rosenstein okay he's quick to
respond to president Trump demanding the
Department of Justice get to the bottom
of it all so Rosen Stein is trying to
make himself out to be a hero but it's a
total farce here's why Rosenstein is
doing what he always does and that is
protecting all of his deep state friends
now the Deputy Attorney General he knows
that by referring this to the inspector
general it will buy them a year to 18
months and protect all these deep state
actors now it's gonna take Michael
Horowitz well over a year
we don't have over a year to uncover
this we need a full FBI DOJ rank and
file field office investigation into all
of this but that's what they're trying
to do is slowly leak out this
information a slow bleed to cover
themselves it's all a cya
and remember they know what's out there
they know they're about to get caught
this is all about controlling the
narrative spinning the narrative trying
to protect themselves and they probably
learned a thing or two from Hillary
about acid washing hard drives we've got
to be careful now there's another major
component to all of this Rosenstein
knows that the Inspector General he
doesn't have any real prosecutorial
power horowitz can't convene a grand
jury
he cannot indict people he could only
give criminal referrals like in the case
of Andrew McCabe and on top of all of
that as we're seeing with this IG report
on the Clinton email investigation the
FBI the DOJ both get to review and try
and refute facts and redact information
again probably falsely in the name of
national security
we have been saying Congress needs to
see these documents we have checks and
balances separation of powers co-equal
branches of government and you know what
they are purposely obstructing and it
looks like some of this might start to
happen all right Sarah Carter she'll
join us in a few minutes breaking
another explosive story tonight here's
the headline concealed FISA documents
may hold the key to trump surveillance
and what Sarah's reporting a number of
very key details that rod Rosenstein he
signed the final FISA warrant you know
using the fake phony dossiers the bulk
of information why to spy on Trump
campaign associate Carter page using the
unverified never corroborated Clinton
bought and paid for foreign national put
together dossier of Russian lies now
Sarah is also reporting the back in
April the FBI refused to turn over
documents that chairman
Nunez and others have been asking for
you know phony claims of national
security risks and as we have seen it's
one excuse to Stonewall after another
all to prevent Congress from knowing the
truth and fulfilling their
constitutional role and chairman Nunez
while he's now putting his foot down and
in this standoff with Rosenstein and the
DOJ good for Devin Nunez take a look we
had a productive what I thought was a
productive meeting and then after that
meeting they've done nothing but leak
and leak and leak now we don't know
exactly who it is over the Department of
Justice or FBI I'm not pinning any blame
on people but we're not going to go to
another meeting where we don't get
documents and then the meeting leaks out
now the Chairman is getting close the
entire truth is now starting to come out
thankfully by the way despite Rosenstein
stonewalling and now because of all of
these new developments you have deep
state actors former Oh communists voting
John Brennan how we ever became CIA
director is beyond any comprehension I
have we know no liar James clapper Sally
Yates we know her political agenda
they're all losing their minds because
all of them are about to be exposed
Brennan lashing out a presidents from
tweeting Senator McConnell speaker Ryan
if mr. Trump continues along this
disastrous path you'll dare major
responsibility for the harm to our
democracy by the way we're a republic
you do a great disservice to the nation
a Republican party if you continue to
enable mr. Trump's self-serving actions
now Brennan is up to his eyeballs in all
of this I am certain that's going to be
exposed and as we have been saying on
this program he's been lying about his
involvement with this Clinton bought and
paid for dossier for months and he lied
in front of Congress and as for James
clapper
he's ensnared in the dossier scandal
also and clapper Oh what is his response
just like Yates just like Brennan let's
go after the president and attack him I
think that's actually very disturbing
assault on the independence the
Department of Justice and I think when
the president this president any
president tries to use the
apartment justice is kind of a private
investigator ybody that's not good for
the country the big thing here is this
is not about spying on it on his
campaign it's about what the Russians
are doing were they attempting to
infiltrate the campaign and that was the
concern and that was it and my my belief
is what the focus of this whole activity
was about the same clapper bragged about
the FBI spying on the Trump campaign and
said it was a good thing this is
problematic and then there's good old
Sally aides who signed off on yes one of
the FISA warrants like Rosenstein and
was emailing with Andrew Weissman the
most corrupt member of Muller's team
after she recused refused to enforce the
travel ban Yates was also trashing the
president why to save and protect
herself
what's this Donald Trump himself
accusing the Obama administration of
improperly targeting his campaign for an
investigation what's your response to
everything you've heard over the weekend
well obviously I'm not going to comment
on the specific facts there it's really
up to the Department of Justice to
decide what information should be made
public with respect to that but you know
I think what we're seeing here is the
president has just taken his all-out
assault on the rule of law to a new
level and this time he is ordering up an
investigation of the investigators who
are examining his own campaign you know
that's really shocking the hard-hitting
interview by liberal Joe now all three
of these deep State players are scared
out of their minds they're directly
implicated in all of this so it's time
to ask what did they all know when did
they all know it and just like I've been
saying about their deep state friend
James Comey who by the way James I
warned you you had the right to remain
silent
you didn't listen anyway instead of
running their mouths
well they might want to now begin to
lawyer up and many of them are yeah
James Comey hired three lawyers the
three people he leaked documents to
great attorney-client privilege for
everybody but me anyway another big
development to tell you about tonight
he's soon to be released DOJ IG report
on the Clinton
email server investigation is expected
to slam FBI leaders just like call me
Andrew McCabe for taking weeks to review
emails that were found on luma
Aberdeen's shared computer with Anthony
Weiner and the IG report is supposed to
come out very soon and if the Inspector
General Horowitz does his job and his
500 employees call me and McCabe should
be very worried tonight all right a lot
of ground to cover